non sto vedendo cosa state vedendo
fatevi vedere anche ove vi prego non mi
tagliate fuori
fatemi vedere il bello che lui vede il
personaggio che comando nel gioco io no
io sono stronzo sarebbe stato figo io
volevo vedere quel vostro problema non
posso guardare le cose va bene fa niente
dai marco fosse una bella [ __ ] tutti a
guardare a finestra ma devo far
uncharted ogni tanto mi mi scatta la
nathan drake che in me
attraverso il condotto così entro
proprio nella finestra dove stanno
guardando tutti che magari c'è un mostro
enorme che mi incula da perché
ovviamente se non puoi guardare bacci
dopo dentro cosa stanno guardando posso
vedere anch'io vi prego sono
curiosissimo ai kahn sia fuckin shit è
comunque un posto enorme quindi deve
essere qualcosa di grosso più grosso del
mio pene grosso entrare entriamo e
stanno mandando al centro della cosa che
stanno guardando tutti fantastico è una
sfera gigante io sia ovviamente salto la
sopra muoio però lo faccio lo stesso
perché piove non sono morti tutti
raccomando vabbè ma che figata
ok c'è la scala
[Musica]
l'iran di frate gira tirati come si gira
allora benz alto salto salto perché
ormai sono diventato nathan drake non
secondo all'altro giornate in cui tutti
guardano qualcosa tu non capisci una
sega però fai finta di capire come a
quando sei a scuola e spiegano
matematica che state guardando questo
sarà ecco stanno guardando questo
dell'acqua state guardando dell'acqua io
ci sono
mi sono infilato dentro fantastico
accettino la leva guardoni della minkia
sucate
e mo chi è a capo adesso deficienti io
sono a cap boy non siete niente tira
tira tira sgancia tutto a fotte sega non
so nemmeno che cosa sto facendo non me
ne frega assolutamente niente tira tutto
ma si sgancia ok ma devo riattivare la
ventola per forza perché se non ci
arriverò mai più ok però tira tira tira
tira perfetto
interfaccia in free
ciao teste di culo a sono nudo come ti
piace guardarmi il pene è brutto
pedofilo stronzo non mi puoi toccare su
un kart su kakà sta indicando cosa c'è
cosa c'è cosa state guardando da un'ora
e mezza brutti cos'è io ho il pistolino
salve cosa cazzo è da casti cosi
maledetti 1 addio esce il sangue puri
schifo 2 se sta roba
trezeguet caso stanno facendo quelli al
vetro sono mai stai dicendo no non lo
faro farlo no cosa è risucchiato ma sto
comandando questa roba
ma è una e una patata gigante figura che
mi guardano tutti teste di culo se solo
potessi farvi del male minchia quanto ne
farei meno fuqua tettuccio alquanto raga
tutto qui dove si pagano in mano
scusate non volevo e la madonna
ok iniziato a scassare un pò livello di
ragazzi è il momento di scassare chi è
che adesso comanda e brutti deficienti
chi comandava vj e la risposta io ti
libererai frate però non posso andare mi
ha chiuso mi hai chiuso zio
volevi tessari culo non ti permettere
non ti permettere chi mi prendo la mia
madre ciao ragazzi tutto a posto tornato
sconfitto in diventato un eroe seguitemi
cazzo insieme sembra che cosa li the
forest quello il nostro leader foris
bellissimo e bellissimo un cazzo una
merda prove non ci arrivo ragazzi datemi
una mano
non è vero ci credo come ma non è
possibile
cos'è questa roba visto vedendo santo
iddio quanto pesa st massa
giorno devo andare a pianisi
chioggia dove ci sono i vetri la gente
guarda mi spiace perché non volevo
vorrei strutturare tutti è magari
un'altra volta accaduto testi di fumo
che sono rotto
però io signò rompo le cose di sempre
che prendo questo in prestito e grazie
alla merda lo porto di qua si sa mai che
serve è la cosa più disgustosa della
figura come riguardano tutti perché
sanno che non possa raggiungerli teste
di minchia vai vai vai vai zio buck ha
aggiunto le fonti
ciao ragazzi è la vostra mensa questa la
zuppa di piselli fa veramente schifo in
groppa loro volto chi ci sta bene
i numeri quelli mi guardano posso
entrare morte
questo ha tutta l'aria di essere il capo
ciao tesoro come stai
è un aspetto fredda piacere fa vj sono
una persona socievole infatti amo gli
abbracci abbracciami sei contento di
aver fatto la mia conoscenza è contento
di aver fatto la mia conoscenza ne sono
più che sicuro che adesso sembra
veramente con i the forest mica come
spiaccicato malissimo mi lavo dal sangue
di quello schifoso che non ci tengo a
essere così sporco berna trave e mi
chiamo questa e sparta è la cosa più
disgustosa allo stesso tempo divertente
che io abbia mai visto in tutta la mia
vita
ok ho capito dopo i cani trani merda
cosa pensate di farmi io sono più grosso
si cagano addosso giustamente anche i
cani fantastico
vai vai vai spingi veloce ce l'ho fatta
non ho idea di dove sto andando
qualsiasi posto va bene ok ok ok di
sotto o cazzo
merda sono ancora vi mica incredibile
posso credere d'altezza assurde sono
ancora vivo a questa porta ma edizione
ciao zio mi aprì la porta per favore
sono qua guarda attaccato al muro
ok grazie fratello sei un [ __ ] genio
un [ __ ] c'erano parla o parole che
ha aperto una moda si fosse una cosa di
cosa sono fatti di melma
non so perché ma sta quell'acqua mi sa
di commestibile mi sembra qualcosa di
vagamente commestibile raga non lo so
perché comunque ragazzi secondo me in
tutto questo io che sono dentro sono
ancora vivo
non so perché io sto presentimento
cadevo schiacciare il pulsante sicuro so
che è rotto ok va bene
l'effetto è più semplice del previsto
vai vai slovan zio siano non ci sia un
inceneritore
ok
dite che mi devo incenerire o cosa vabbè
dai vincere a rischio nel dubbio
vai fratte vai frate non entra
non mi devo incenerire peccato sarebbe
stato figo devo lanciare questa cosa qua
dentro titolo ok faccio scattare
l'allarme antincendio 9 geniale la
prendo al volo tipo all'uomo al volume
noche cazzo non sei un buon quaterback
veloce però meraviglioso e una è andata
ora qui sopra quella quali sopra cui si
stanca gandhi in mano e due fa chi è
solo fatta veloci zio veloce
non so bene dove la devo portare ma
servirà per forza se no il cazzo ok ecco
lo buttava quest'opera vai
quindi ha quindi posso andare avanti
grazie fantastico mi sto facendo strada
solo io
mentre la gente guarda bach e handel
spoleto big potato head la merda a è
solo dovrò prima che cazzo stanno
facendo quelli da questo coso qua mi
hanno insegnato a scuola è come si
pilota sta roba
orc a mignano flusso capito che ci sono
fra the city forte do regalo buon natale
si passa in un rincoglionito zio ma poi
essere veramente così [ __ ]
ma come tu sei sfondato il muro ed è un
genio non ho ben capito che cosa volesse
fare il tizio ma ok tanto sto gioco non
ho mai capito un cazzo mineo eccolo
arriverà il tuo momento di morire fra te
lo dico io se riuscissi ad attivarlo
prima volevo schiacciarti ma non ci sono
riuscito a grazie a questi mi stanno
aiutando tipo credo è o mi stanno
aiutando sono dei completi [ __ ]
quindi credo mi stanno aiutando sicuro
ma i ragazzi mi stanno aiutando perché
ho ammazzato il loro capo che lì sotto
parlava di brutto tempismo su veloce ce
l'ha fatta
salve siete amanti del curling come me e
guardano tranquilli come se non potessi
far nulla perché siete così tranquilli
riguardano tutti tranquilli come se
niente fosse c'è una setticemia figli di
p ma veramente non ci credo mano su
tutto di brutto o reagan non me
l'aspettavo proprio
ma hanno [ __ ] veramente bravi
complete grazie aprite che giochiamo
insieme giochiamo ad palla avvelenata io
faccio la palla e ci sarà un modo per
evadere da qua però ve lo devo dire
siete dei [ __ ] area mi
rinchiude te quale entrò e mi tappezzate
coso di colla vinilica c'e ma grazie al
cazzo che evadono devo sradicare solo la
ex a posto ma era più facile del
previsto ragazzi fuori fuori fuori frate
bravissimo non era così difficile
veramente legami che potevate studiarla
un po meglio sta cosa pure mia sorella
fuggiva da lì volendo per tra l'altro
variazione cosa che non ho capito ma sta
palla è fatta di cody di di esseri umani
o
normali o che cos'altro cioè non capito
hanno mischiato degli esseri umani per
trasformarli in una patata gigante
volevano fotter milano sono riusciti
manco di striscio scusami birillo tu non
avevi contro sì ma mica sono un
impiastro lega spacco qualsiasi cosa c'è
la luce la luce signora rica tutto forte
come se dovessi sfondare la madre degli
haters 6 cazzo ok
ecco forse questo è peggio di una
valanga e la valanga inter iata delle
meglio fa chi è bene
sono uscito c'è il mare veramente sono
riuscito a fuggire
no non ci credo mai frate muoviti che
c'è il mare nuota sono morto rega non va
più un cazzo
c'è una patata arenata in spiaggia se
qualche bagnino passasse mai ma almeno
porta il ketchup
a tanto si sta togliendo lo zoom proprio
cinematica molto poetica questa cosa
sempre sognato di vedere una patata
davanti al mare farò vedere la mia
futura ragazza questo video per
rimorchiare e ci mancherebbe altro
quindi
cosa
ma veramente
ma che come è finito così eric rodriguez
perdersi che cazzo stai dicendo c'è
qualche problema di fondo questo è il
finale di inside hanno fatto tutto un
bordello per far andare un bambino
dentro una fabbrica che poi non l'ha
lobotomizzato ma bensì è riuscito a
fuggire per trasformarsi in una patata
gigante e finire arenato su una spiaggia
per poi vedere i titoli di coda
va bene fatemi uscire il bambino dalla
patata almeno non può finire così vi
prego la cosa è eva se mi volete dire
che io mi sono fatto tutto dall'inizio
questo bambino che scende da sto muro
per poi finire dentro una patata arenata
sulla spiaggia questo era il finale di
inside
non me l'aspettavo così sono sincero non
pensavo una roma un po più diversa non è
per niente scontato il finale almeno
quello cioè non è scontato ma dai
ragazzi questo è stato inside 2 miliardi
di pollici super il finale però va beh
non era brucia e non era scontato io
quando ci sono i finali scontati mi
girano le palle quindi almeno non era
scontato era strano quindi ragazzi spero
che inside vi sia piaciuto spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto tranquilli
che dalla settimana prossima inizierà
una nuova serie che spero vi piaccia che
al posto di inside è stata una delle
serie più belle che io abbia mai giocato
negli ultimi tempi credo sicuramente
nella top 5 del canale via niente
ragazzi concluso che l'episodio spero
che vi sia piaciuto come assoluto
bisogno su un momento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook con video
tornare descrizione scuse rifiuti 62 cp
diavolo prossimo vito e ragazzi